le ministre de l'intérieur est donc
immédiatement auditionné après les
syndicats un sourire et une apparente
décontraction qui cache mal la gêne du
premier flic de france
le constat accablant dressé par les
syndicats a créé beaucoup d'attentes
chez les sénateurs
mais face à la commission gérard collomb
donne l'impression de découvrir la faire
moi je croyais que monsieur benalla
était policier
compte tenu des deux ce qui ce passe moi
j'en découvre chaque jour sur les
personnalités
je lis les journaux comme vous et il ya
toute une partie de l'histoire de
monsieur benalla que franchement je
découvre de plus en plus eh bien
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
heureusement qu'il ya les journaux pour
vous offrir la gérard collomb vous savez
c'est la sagesse des trois singes c'est
j'ai rien vu j'ai rien entendu et je
peux rien dire à la donc c'était là
aussi assez surréaliste